just a word of warning if a video
blogger ever says this this videos going
to be kind of short today because I've
unfortunately got quite a lot of stuff
to do they are without a doubt
completely and utterly lying
they aren't busy at all their life is
just so unbelievably boring that they
just don't have very much to talk to you
about just as a side note this video is
going to be kind of short today because
I unfortunately got quite a lot of stuff
to do
I've got a lot of them breathing and
cooing and pausing to do what is this
video even about what's the title oh yes
so every now and again to help punctuate
my mundane existence on this planet
I'll be walking down a road let's say
and somebody will stop me and say oh my
god is that you and you are you are you
the guy who did the thing with the tea
is that you and I will usually do a
little bit of giggling at the oddness of
the situation because I'm still not used
to it and I'll say yes that really odd
thing that you saw on the internet yes
that was that was me but whenever I do
get recognized from this internet thing
that I do people are always very very
lovely but as well as having people bump
into me I also every now and again will
get an email from someone saying I was
walking down such-and-such a road at
such-and-such a time I saw someone who
looked exactly like you was it you and I
will say yeah that was me why didn't you
come up and say hi you silly person so
what I decided to do TM to rectify the
situation of people not approaching me
in the streets is make you all a
littleincentive if at any point during
your life you ever spot me IRL I want
you to stop me I want you to point my
face and I want you to say I found you
and if you do that I'll give you an I
found charlie pin badge the rules
regarding these are that you can only
get one if you catch me at a point where
I am boringly living my life which means
that if you find me any kind of
organized event I would not be giving
you one they're strictly reserved for
people who find me walking down the
streets for eating a pasty or peeing in
a public bathroom and I don't want any
half heartedness either right if you're
gonna point and shout at me I want you
to point and shout at me no I've found
you Charlie shout shout like your life
depends on it because it does it depends
on a badge no please don't go thinking
that oh you're never gonna spot me in
real life because although it is very
unlikely given the number of people on
this earth
do remember that unlikely things happen
all the time so please keep your eyes
peeled and
forward to some of you pointing in my
face and shouting bye you've just had
the almost imponderable joy of watching
Charlie is so cool like which makes you
like cool